الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده التي توصف
باليمنيه الاشد تطرفا في تاريخ اسرائيل
استهلت يومها الاول بتصعيد دائما ضد
الفلسطينيين لما اسفر عن سقوط قتلى وجرحى
اضافه الى غاره جويه استهدفت مطار دمشق
الدولي اخرجته عن الخدمه الى حين وصل
مخاوف محليات ودوليه من برنامجها اعلن
نتنياهو ان اولويه حكومته احباطما وصفه
لمسع ايران امتلاك سلاح النمو
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي ابرز الرسائل
التي صدرت عن حكومه نتنياهو في يومها
الاول تجاه الفلسطينيين وعامه المنطقه
هل تتجه اسرائيل بقياده هذه الحكومه نحو
سلوك اكثر تصعيدا مع الفلسطينيين وهل تاتي
تصريحات وزير الامن القومي
اقتحام الاقصى في هذا السياق
والى اين سيؤول التوتر مع ايران في ضوء
تبادل الطرفين رسائل التهديد
[موسيقى]
اجنده مزدحمه لحكومه يستعجل رئيسها
تنفيذها منذ اليوم الاول لبدايه عهدته
هكذا جاءت الاشارات ورسائل من الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده تلك التي يصفها
منتقدها بانها الاكثر يمنيه والاشد تطرفا
في تاريخ اسرائيل
بقتل وجرح واعتقال للمزيد من الفلسطينيين
استهلا بنيمنت اليهود رئسته للوزراء مشددا
على ضروره منع ايران من امتلاك السلاح
النووي وعلى استهداف حلفائها واذرعها في
المنطقه مترجمه
الاثنين في بلده كفردان غربي جنين في
الضفه المحتله
وقد قتلت قوته الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بالرصاص شابين هما فؤاد عابد ومحمد حوشيه
خلال عمليه اقتحام للبلده
مسار الظروف طبيه فلسطينيه افادت باصابه
عدد من الفلسطينيين وصفت جراحه احدهم
بالخطيره خلال مواجهات المعكوه الاحتلال
وكانت قوه اسرائيليه اقتحمت بلده كفردان
وهدمت منزلي عائلتي الشهيدين احمد وعبد
الرحمن عابد الذين تتهممه مع اسرائيل بقتل
ضابط اسرائيلي في عمليه المسلح عند حاجز
الجلمه في سبتمبر الماضي
كما اعتقلت قوته الاحتلال في الساعه
الاخيره
34 فلسطينيه من انحاء متفرقه في الضفه
الغربيه
وبحسب نادي الاسير الفلسطيني تركز في
الاعتقالات في كل من رام الله والخليل
وبيت لحم ونابلس وسلفي وجنين واقتادت قوه
الاحتلال المعتقلين الى مراكز امنيه
للتحقيق معهم بتهمه مقاومه الاحتلال
شرروا حكومه نتنياهو وصل الى الداخل
السوري اذ قالت وزاره النقل السوريه ان
مطار دمشق الدولي عاد الى الخدمه بعد
اصلاح الاضرار الناجمه عن غارات اسرائيليه
استهدفت وكانت وكاله الانباء الرسميه سنه
نقلت عن مصدر عسكريا ان عسكريين قتل وجرح
اثنان اخرا في قصف صاروخيا اسرائيلي على
اهداف في جنوب دمشق ولم يصدر اي تعليق بعد
عن الجيش الاسرائيلي على الهجوم
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من رام الله
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي امين عام المبادره
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ومن واشنطن الدكتور
خليل العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه دكتور مصطفى دكتور خليل
اهلا بكما كل عام وانتم بخير اذا ابدا معك
دكتور مصطفى
الجديده ونحن فيما يبدوا مثل السباق او
تسابق بين تصريحات وممارسات
فعليا هل تجد ان هذا هناك توافق
ام ان هذا التسابق حتى يفوق التوقعات
هو ما نسمعه هذه الحكومه بالذات لم تخفي
نواياها على الاطلاق
وقالت ان برنامجها وهاي الرساله اللي وجهت
للفلسطينيين والعرب عموما
برنامجها وبرنامج ضم وتهويد للضفه الغربيه
بكاملها
وبرنامجها واستيطان شرس سيتم توسيعه بصوره
غير مسبوقه ليس فقط في الضفه الغربيه بل
حتى فيما تبقى من اراضي لدى الفلسطينيين
في الداخل في الجليل والنقب والمثلث وهذه
الحكومه هددت بانها ستعمل على تغيير
الواقع في المسجد الاقصى في تحدي لمشاعر
كل الفلسطينيين والعرب والمسلمين
وتقول بصريح العباره ان الضفه الغربيه
بكام الهوى ان كل فلسطين التي يسمونها
ايرث اسرائيل هي ارض لليهود فقط حكر
لليهود فقط وهي فقط فيها حق تقرير مصير
اليهود ماذا يعني كل ذلك يعني نحن لا
نواجه ما اسرائيل في الواقع نحن نواجه
حركه صهيونيه قررت في هذه مرحله ان تكشف
كل نواياها بشكل كامل وخلاصه مواقفها ليست
فقط تكريس نظام الابارتيد العنصري وانما
التهديد بتطهير عرقي ضد الشعب الفلسطيني
نحن نواجه في هذه المرحله الدرجه من تطور
الحركه الصهيونيه بحيث ان حكمتها ليست فقط
اكثر تطرفا وعنصريه بل هي حكومه فاشيه
وكما يقول حتى بعض الاسرائيليين فيها
نازيين جدد مثل بين كبير وسنوترش هذا تطور
خطير له جانبان الجانب الاول سيؤدي الى
انفجار بالتاكيد ليس فقط في فلسطين
بالربما يمتد هذا الانفجار للمنطقه باسرها
ولكن من ناحيه ثانيه انا برايي هذه
الحكومه ستفشل لانها لن تستطيع ان تكسر لا
اراده الشعب الفلسطيني ولا اسرارها على
المقاومه بالعكس ما تقوم به هذا البرنامج
هو يدفع فلسطينيين جميعا نحو الوحده ونحو
ادراك انه لا علاقه يمكن ان تكون معهم الا
المقاومه والكفاح والنظام والعمل على
مقاطعتهم وفرض العقوبات عليهم
لا يهمها هذه الحكومه ان تفشل همم بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين هي تريد ان تظهر بمظهر القوه
في الداخل الاسرائيلي بدليل يعني اذا
نظرنا الى ما حصل حتى الان همم اقتحام
دائما وعق- واعتقال للعشرات همم غاره
باتجاه سوريا ايضا همم موقف اكثر تجددا
تجددا باتجاه همم ايران هل يمكن القول ان
هذه هي همم العناوين هذه تشكل منهج او
ربما برنامج الحكومه الجديده
والى اي حد هي مستعده ان تذهب باتجاه
تحقيقه دكتور خليل العناني
ولا مساء الخير استاذه ليلى وكل عام وانت
بخير وتحيه للدكتور مصطفى لكل الساده
المشاهدين نعم نحن ايذاء حكومه فالشياكه
دكتور مصطفى مطرفه
دينيه تقوم على عده عوامل او عده امور
الامر الاول هو كما قال الدكتور مصطفى
الايمان باسرائيل الكبرى تمتد من البحر
الى النهر محاوله زياده توسيع رقعه
الاستيطان صلاه الظهر في الغربيه في القدس
متعلق بالاقصى ما يتعلق بالتقسيم الزماني
والمكاني في استخدام المسند الاقصى ولذلك
اقتحام بشكل او باخر من قبل ما تصرح اليوم
او كان بالتكات كده بالتغريد انت تقول
بانه يستعد ليه اقتحام الاقصى كما يتعلق
قبل ثلاث سواء كان عندما كان لعبه في
الكنيسه او كان بشكل فردي وبالتالي احنا
غذاء حكومه هي بالاساس حكومه حسب المعايير
الاسرائيليه الحكومه المتطرفه يعني قراتها
قبل ايام تصريحات المسؤول اسرائيليين سواء
من خلال رئيس الاسرائيلي الذي يتحدث عن
نجاح حكومه متطرفه وانها قد تؤدي الى
عواقب وخ جدك لما يتعلق باسرائيل ايضا
رئيس الوزراء اسرائيل السابق يا ايرلبيه
تحدث ايضا وحذر من هذا النهج المتطرف لهذه
الحكومه الجديده وبالتالي نحن اجزاء وضع
جديد في اسرائيل تجاه باتجاه اليمين
الفاشي تكريس لمساله الابارتيد للعنصريه
الاسرائيليه للفشيه وبالتالي قد تكون امر
فعلا له تداعيات حتى اقليميه كما ذكرت
السودا ليلى نعم هناك اجنده اقليميه تتعلق
اولا بالتسخين والتصعيد والتحريض الدايران
محاوله تخريب اي ساعه غرب ليه احياء
الاتفاق النووي الايراني في عام 2015
محاوله استئناف العمليات العسكريه الديران
وكنا نعلم جميعا انه اثناء فتره الثانيه
والاولى كان هناك استهداف لعلماء نهويين
ايرانيين سواء في الصواريخ البالستيه او
في همم في الوقود النووي الايراني هناك
عمليات عسكريه او عمليات سريه خارج ايران
ايضا همم هناك تحرير بشكل كامل على ايران
وبالتالي نحن ايذاء شهور ساخنه قادمه في
ما يتعلق الحكومه الجديده طيب يعني انت
شارت الى تحذيرات لافيد بشان ربما اقتحام
الاقصى و دكتور مصطفى همم قالها صراحه
ثاني يعني ولكن الفرق وكان يفعل ذلك في
السابق الفرق انه في منصب جديد هو الان
وزير امن
والتوسع للسطاني ايضا موجود
ومستمر على ما يبدو ليس هناك يعني تغيير
في هذه النقطه يعني هذا ما نريد ان نفهم
يعني ما الذي تحمله هذه الحكومه الجديده
بهذا الاتجاه بحيث يجعلها مختلفه
هذه الحكومه
تفضل لمن لمن السؤال دكتور مصطفى
الواقع هذه الحكومه طبعا جميع الحكومات
الاسرائيليه كانت متطرفه وعنصريه يجب ان
لا ننسى ان حكومه لبيد نفسه
قامت باقدمت على قتل 224 شهيد فلسطيني
منهم 50 طفل وكان هذا اعلى رقم منذ عام
2005 في الضفه الغربيه
واقدمت على اعتقال 7000 اسير في سنه واحده
واقدمت على عمليات توسع استيطاني ايضا غير
مسبوقه لذلك نحن لا نتحدث عن انه هذه
الحكومه المتطرفه الوحيده ولكن ايضا هذه
حكومها اكثر من متطرفه هي حكومه فاشيه
بالمعنى الحرفي للكلمه يعني مفرطه في
تطرفها وانا برايي فعلا الحركه الصهيوني
قررت ان تسير في طريق القمع الفاشل للشعب
الفلسطيني من ناحيه
وممارسه التهويد والضم تعتقد ان ميزان
القوه يسمح لها الان ان تقوم بضم الضفه
الغربيه بكل وضوح وصراحه وهي في نفس الوقت
تنتهي اخر يعني له علاقه بايران وهذا
التكتيك هي في الوقت الذي تعمل في على
الضم والتهويد وتغيير الواقع في المسجد
الاقصى تريد ان تهمش
وتحيد القضيه الفلسطينيه عبر تصعيد
التطبيع مع المحيط العربي ولذلك نتنه يعلن
الان انه في طريقه لزياره الامارات وانه
سيحاول ان يعمق التطبيع ويوسعه لماذا لا
يريد ان يهمش القضيه الفلسطينيه كي يستطيع
ان يصفها وهجوم على ايران لهدفين الهدف
الاول ان ان ذلك يساعد في جذب الانظار عن
القضيه الفلسطينيه وكان الموضوع فقط هو
الموضوع مع ايران وهذا يساعد اسرائيل ان
تبدو انها ضحيه وهي ترتكب الجريمه الاكبر
في تاريخ البشريه الحديث وفي نفس الوقت هو
يريد ان يضعف ايران طبعا لانه لا يريد ان
تكون هناك اي قوه في المنطقه يمكن ان
تنافس اسرائيل وبالمناسبه هو يتعامر ليس
فقط على ايران يتامر على مصر يتامر على
سوريا يهاجم سوريا كما رايتهم
لتفتيت سوريا ويريد ان يفتت وسعه الى ضرب
العراق ويسعوا الان الى ضرب ايران لانه
اسرائيل تريد ان هذه حكومه تريد ان تفرض
هيمنه الحركه الصهيونيه على المحيط باسره
سياسيا واقتصاديا واجتماعيا ومن جميع
النواحي الاخرى منهم من هنا يبدو الخطر
واضحا ليس فقط على الشعب الفلسطيني وانما
على كل الشعوب العربيه بس في تاثير مهم من
ناحيه فلسطينيه انه فتره طويله ل 28 عام
ساده وهم لدى جزء من الفلسطينيين على
المستوى الرسمي لان من الممكن التفاوض مع
حكومات اسرائيل والوصول الى حل وسط هذه
الحكومه ترسل رساله لجميع لا حل وسط مع
الفلسطينيين يريد ضم وتهويد كامل وبالتالي
ليس امام الشعب الفلسطيني الا بديل واحد
المقاومه وهذه الحكومه لن ترضع بالبيانات
ولا بالاستنكرات ستردع فقط بالمقاومه
الفعليه على الارض وبحركه لفرد المقاطعه
والعق عليها دوليا وانا برايي الان امام
فرصه ذهبيه لا تعوض لفرض العقوبات
والمقاطعه على اسرائيل
التي تحدث عليها الدكتور مصطفى للتو دكتور
خليل العناني هذه الرساله لا يقراها فقط
الفلسطينيون يقراها العالم كله
وهناك انتقادات لا نقل من الجميع لكن هناك
انتقادات
ويعني نبرتها ربما بدات تتغير الى حد ما
خصوصا في الفتره الاخيره
حتى الاداره الامريكيه نفسها همم يعني
والتي جددت التزامها بحل الدولتين كانها
موقف يعني همم في هذا الوقت هل تغيير
الحكومه الجديده حكومه نادانياه
اهميه لمثل هذه الاصوات
بشكل او باخر للحركه الصهيونيه الدينيه من
المطر في الفاشل في اسرائيل هو ايضا
نتنياهو نفسه كان يريد هذه الحكومه باي
ثمن و باي طريقه حلف مع اكثر الاحزاب
تطرفا ويمنيه في اسرائيل هدفه الرئيسي هو
بالاساس هو ان يتم تابعه نفسه من خلال
التشريعات جديده في الكون في الكونست تقوم
بامكانيه ان يتخلص من المحاكم التي
بانتظار بشكل او باخره بالتلاوه في سبيل
ذلك قام بالتضحيه بكل شيء همم فيما يتعلق
بالبعد الدولي او البعد الخارجي هناك
بالفاكهه السودانيه انتقادات وليس فقط
انتقادات كلمات هناك ايضا اجراءات على
سبيل المثال هناك ايقاف وتوقف الاستثمارات
من الوجهيه هي اسرائيل الاعتراض على هذه
الحكومه سمعنا بالامس تصريحات من قبل
مسؤول امريكيين بعضها جاء على اللسان كده
يتحدث عن التزام حاله دولتين همم برفض
مساله مساله الاستعارها هناك احتمال زياره
لجاك سوليفان الامريكي خلال منتصف الشهر
الحالي من اجل تاكيد للحل الامريكي
للدولتين او النظره الامريكيه لحل
الدوبلتين ولكن بشكل عام ليس هناك اعتبار
كبير لهذه المسائل ما لم يكن هناك
السياسات فعليه تقوم بها امريكا ودول
غربيه بفرضيه على اسرائيل من الصعب بوجود
امتثال اسرائيل كما قلت قبل قليل هناك همم
استخفاف واستهان من قبل نتنياهو حلفاء
بهذه المساله ادهم هناك نوع من ال- ال-
التراجع الدولي في هذه القناه الفلسطينيه
ليس هناك دعم بشكل كامل هناك قبل ايام
قليله عندما تم التصوير في المجلس الامن
في الامم المتحده تحديدا على همم تاكيد
على فكره الاحتلال في اسرائيل هناك رفض
لدواء الغربيه على راسها مثلا امريكا رفضت
التصويت على هذه المساله ودول الاخرى
امتنعت عن التصويت وبالتاليس هناك موقف في
غربي قوي من هذه المساله بالعكس هناك نوع
من همم المهادنه نوع من التواصل فيما
يتعلق الفلسطينيين
طاقه ربما من المناسب الان ان ننظر فقط
همم الى همم تصريحات معينه بشان العلاقه
بين حكومه نتنياهو واداره بايدا والسؤال
كيف ستكون هذا السؤال يفرده الخلاف بين
الجانبين في عدد من الملفات المهمه
كالموقف مثلا من حل الدولتين كما قلنا
الاستيطان والنووي الايراني في بين
التهنئه بتشكيل الحكومه الرئيس الامريكي
ايضا قال ان الولايات المتحده ستستمر في
دعم حل دولتين ومعارضه السياسات التي تعرض
للخطر قابليه هذا الحل للحياه او تتعارض
مع مصالحنا وقيامنا المشتركه دكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي ماذا تقرا في ثنايا هذا التصريح
اقرا عدم رغبه في الضغط على اسرائيل عدم
رغبه من الولايات المتحده ان تتخذ موقف
جدي من هذه من هذا التطور الخطير في
اسرائيل
وهم يرون حل الدولتين يتم اغتياله امام
عيونهم وانا براي صار حل للدولتين قفص
يريد ان يضعوا فيه الفلسطينيين كي يواصلوا
الحديث عنه وفي نفس الوقت اسرائيل تلتهم
ما تبقى من الارض انا برايي بالعكس الشعار
الوطني الفلسطيني يجب ان يكون واجب ان
تفهم الولايات المتحده هذا الامر ليس فقط
انهاء الاحتلال وانما ايضا اسقاط نظام
الابر تايد العنصري في كل فلسطين
التاريخيه بدون بدون استثناء همم بما في
ذلك يافا وحيفا وعكا والجليل والمثلث
والنقب هذا هو الرد الصحيح على هؤلاء وانا
برايي الولايات المتحده تتجنب اتخاذ
اجراءات ضد اسرائيل اليوم وصلت الى
اسرائيل اليوم طائرات اف 15 امريكي جاي
تشارك اسرائيل في مناورات عسكريه يعني هذا
هو الواقع الولايات المتحده ترفض ان تمارس
ضغط على اسرائيل وانا برايي في وجود حكومه
فاشيه فاسده يعني الفساد والفشير اخت ليلى
هو ما يميز هذه الحكومه نحن لا يجب ان
ننتظر تغيير من الولايات المتحده وان كان
الوضع محرز الولايات المتحده التغيير
سيحدث بالضبط كما جرى في حاله جنوب
افريقيا وهذا ما قلناه منذ سنوات لن يحدث
التغيير في البدايه على مستوى الحكومات
سيحدث على التغيير على مستوى الشعوب على
مستوى الطلاب على مستوى الاحزاب والنقابات
والبرلمانات
بالمقاطعه وفرض العقوبات على اسرائيل
وتدريجيا ستضطر الحكومات ان تسير في هذا
الطريق ولكن هذا يتطلب من كل يعني هذا
بالنسبه
عن التناغم هل فعلا تملك النسيج همم
السياسي الكامل حيث تدعم تدعم هذه الاجنده
التي همم تطمح لها هذه الحكومه
من الناحيه كحرك صهيونيه بدون شك هذه
الحكومه تحظى بالتاييد الكامل لانه
مكوناتها الصهيونيه تدفع في نفس الاتجاه
ولكن يجب ان نرى ايضا انه هاي اكثر حبوب
ستؤدي الى تفتت داخلي في اسرائيل
بتحديد بسبب همم ما ذكره زميل قبل قليل
وهي الاصوليه الدينيه اليهوديه المصيطره
والتي تتناقض مع الاتجاه الالماني في
اسرائيل هذا يسبب حاله تفتت داخلي
اسرائيلي يساعدنا في معركتنا وفينا ولكن
ايضا هناك فجوه كبرى الان تنشا بين هذه
المنظومه الحاكمه في اسرائيل بفسادها
وبفاشيتها مع جزء كبير من المجتمعات
اليهوديه في الخارج انا لا اقول انه
الحركه الصهيونيه لم تدعم هذه الحكومه بكل
طاقتها بالتاكيد ولكن انا اقول ان هناك
نقاط ضعف في عسكرهم في داخلهم في داخل
اسرائيل نفسها يمكن لنا ان نستفيد منها
ونستغلها في لفرد المقاطعه والعقوبات
نقطه المح لها الدكتور مصطفى قبل قليل كيف
تقرا انت اعلان نتنياهو بدا جولاته
الخارجيه
بزياره عاصمه عربيه
امور الامر الاول انه استمرار المسلسل
التطبيع بين الطرفين الاماراتي والاسرائيل
هناك حاله تحالف استراتيجي تقريبا بين
البلدين لمده توقعات ابراهام في 20 20 همم
هناك سعيه امراه حفيذ جدا لوجود علاقات
قويه مع اسرائيل سواء فيما يتعلق الامر
بعلاقات اقتصاديه وقرانا وسمعنا وهنعرف
جميعنا هناك على الاقل استثمارات اماراتيه
بحوالي 10 مليار دولار في اسرائيل ايضا
هناك محاوله لاستخدام الملف الايراني ملف
ايران انه فيما يتعلق باستخدام كفزاع من
قبل اسرائيل من اجل ضمان وجود تاييد
اماراتي لها بشكل او اخر عدد هناك محاوله
للدفع العلاقات التطبيع مع الدول الاخرى
ربما نشات في الايام المقبله او الشهور
المقبله تطبيع مع السعوديه مع دول عربيه
اخرى نتيجه لوجود نوع من الزخم الاماراتي
في هذه المساله والمحزن في الامر انه ليس
هناك مشكله لدى الامارات في وجود حكومه
صهيونيه متطرفه ورايين قبل اسابيع قليله
استضافه السفاره الاماراتيه في تل ابيب بن
جرير نفسه في الاحتفال باليوم الوطني
الاماراتي في همم يعني مخزي لحد بعيد ولا
الثلاثه هناك مشكله اماراتيه في وجود
حكومه متطرفه ليس فقط بالمعايير العربيه
والعالميه بالمعايير الايصاليه نفسها كما
قلنا قبل قليل وبالتالي احد الاهداف
الرئيسيه لتلياهو من اجل الهروب ومشاكله
الداخليه هو التطبيع مع ال- ال- العالم
العربي كما قال دكتور مصطفى مش قضايا
الفلسطينيه
الايراني
دكتور خليل العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه من واشنطن شكرا للدكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي امين عام المبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه من رام الله
وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا على متابعه هذه الحلقه
من ما وراء الخبر
[موسيقى]